in august 2020 the world's hottest
temperature
ever might have been recorded 54 degrees
celsius in death valley california
scorching deserts aren't the only places
feeling the heat
on the other extreme a siberian town
reached 38 degrees this year
a new high above the arctic circle
places around the world are undergoing
more frequent and
intense hot weather in 2018
two weeks of heat in japan caused more
than a thousand deaths
and more than 70 000 hospitalizations
as temperatures rise many are at risk
from elderly people to those who work
outside
on farms and construction sites
a federal report predicts tens of
thousands of deaths by the end of the
century
in the united states alone but
researchers say a majority of
related deaths and injuries can be
prevented
with straightforward solutions
it starts with understanding how heat
stroke sets in
this occurs when the core body reaches
about 40 degrees celsius
or three degrees higher than most
people's average temperature
when internal sensors tell the brain
that the body is warming
blood vessels close to the skin expand
to promote cooling
if this doesn't lower the body's
temperature the heart will start pumping
more blood to redirect
fluids and the body will begin sweating
humans can sweat up to two liters an
hour
under strenuous conditions if a person
becomes dehydrated
the adrenal gland releases a fluid
regulating hormone in the kidneys
to reduce urine production
too much fluid loss makes it harder for
the heart to maintain
blood pressure if blood pressure
decreases
the body's internal temperature can
climb rapidly
people with weaker hearts are more
vulnerable to heat stroke
a crucial step is immersion in cold
water within 30 minutes of heat stroke
or exhaustion
restoring hydration is also important
but in one study participants thirst was
quenched
well before they replenish their lost
fluids
making sure to drink the right amount of
water to avoid dehydration
helps the body stay cool for outdoor
workers in particular
adapting to the heat is key the body can
adjust to changing conditions quite
quickly
researchers found that after individuals
spent just two
hours a day under the hot sun for a week
their core body temperatures lowered and
they started sweating at lower
temperatures
unfortunately chronic use of air
conditioning
stunts these adaptations instead
cooling down with a fan which is cheaper
and requires less energy
is more effective another easy technique
is splashing cold water on the skin like
sweating the cold water cools the body
as it evaporates
but without the body's loss of fluids
in 2020 an average of 21 days in the
summer
were too hot for people to work in the
united states
this number is expected to double by
2050.
research that helps people adapt to the
heat and know how to respond when things
go wrong
can prevent future deaths
you